ambiance kuduro ce matin là au centre
d'accueil loisirs les loupiots de
plaisir comme chaque mercredi cette
structure de la commune accueille près
d'une quarantaine d'enfants âgés de 3 à
10 ans encadrés par des animateurs de la
ville à vous croire
4-4 peut mieux faire
après ce moment libre dans la cour place
aux activités du matin
thibault a préparé quatre jeux de
réflexion et d'attention j'ai des
valeurs et le mont but ça va être des
données les vannes à ses valeurs aux
enfants par le biais d'activités par le
biais de petits jeux de de consignes de
règles c'est ce qui compte en fait c'est
d'être à l'écouté des enfants de pouvoir
toujours raide sous la surveillance mais
de faire des champs en même temps de son
côté bénédicte est parti avec quelques
jeunes au gymnase léo lagrange un
tournoi de football inter centres
d'accueil de loisirs est organisée
durant la matinée depuis 2007 elle
exerce le métier d'animatrice à plaisir
après un bep sanitaire et social et son
brevet d'aptitude aux fonctions
d'animateur quand les enfants ils
viennent nous voir et nous disent oui
c'était bien c'était génial on en voit
encore
voilà c'est ça en fait qui fait plaisir
de voir les enfants contents et heureux
mais c'est la base du métier durant
l'été la commune ouvre quatre accueils
de loisirs les enfants sont accueillis
de 7h30 à 18h 45 du lundi au vendredi
les animateurs travaillent entre 47 et
48 heures par semaine pour des
indemnités moyenne de 2000 euros la
ville recherche actuellement des
collaborateurs pour compléter ses
équipes
ou est ce qu'on attend c'est surtout du
dynamisme du peps une bonne logique
à défaut de beaucoup d'expérience on
leur demande d'avoir une certaine
logique
une organisation un peu de rigueur on a
eu des étudiants qui sont en école d'art
qui vont pouvoir ouvrir un peu les
activités sur tout ce qui est artistique
c'est là que pour nous c'est vraiment un
plus c'est c'est un bon apprentissage
que d'être déjà animateur parce que
voilà ça permet aux plus jeunes parfois
de trouver c'est justement ce petit job
d'été et puis et puis il faut savoir que
plus tard sur un cv c'est une belle
expérience prochaine session de
recrutement organisée à la maison de
l'emploi de plaisir mercredi 29 mai de
12h à 17h30